IT'S TIME TO PLAY
"DISINFOMERCIAL."
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS ARE
AWARE OF THIS, BUT AFTER YOU
FALL ASLEEP TV STILL HAPPENS,
LIKE REALLY LATE AT NIGHT.
BUT DON'T WORRY ABOUT ANYTHING
THAT HAPPENS AFTER 12:30, IT'S A
A LOT OF BULL( BLEEP ).
EXCEPT, OF COURSE, FOR
THE COMMERCIALS THAT GO FOR
THINGS SO STUPID, YOU TRICK
YOURSELF INTO THINKING YOU NEED
THOSE THINGS.
THESE PRODUCTS ARE SO DUMB, THEY
CANNOT EVEN MAKE A FULL
INFOMERCIAL ABOUT THEM.
BUT LUCKILY, THEY STILL FIND
THEIR WAY INTO THE YOUTUBES.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU RIDICULOUS
PRODUCTS, AND FOR 250 POINTS YOU
NEED TO TELL ME WHY I NEED THAT
PRODUCT, ALL RIGHT?
FIRST UP, SOMETHING FOR THIS
GUY'S ASS.
>> BEASTLY BUTT ODOR?
HOW DO YOU STOP THE STINK?
HI. I'M ADAM JAY, AND THIS IS
DOC BOTTOM'S A SPRAY.
>> CHRIS: KURT.
>> WE'LL HANDLE THE BUTT SMELL.
YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHY GROWN
MEN KEEP SMELLING YOUR BUTT
HOLE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MARY LYNN?
>> IT'S MORE EXPENSE AND I HAVE
HARDER TO USE THAN SOAP.
( LAUGHTER )
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
AH, I CAN'T -- UGH.
NEXT ONE: HOW ABOUT THIS GLOVE
FOR PEOPLE WHO DAENT STOP
TOUCHING THEIR MEAT, EVEN WHEN
IT'S STILL COOKING.
>> THE GRILL GLOVE'S DESIGNED TO
GIVE YOU THE PERFECT GRIP FOR
EVERY FLIP.
HOT POTATOES ARE HARD TO HANDLE.
BUT THE GLOVE RESISTS
TEMPERATURES UP TO 500 DEGREES
MAKING IT PERFECT FOR HOT BAKED
POTATOES AND MORE.
>> CHRIS: DO YOU-- WHY DO YOU
HAVE TO PICK A ( BLEEP ) POTATO
OFF A GRILL WITH YOUR BARE
HANDS?
OH, THIS IS IMPOSSIBLE!
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING!
THOMAS.
>> ALSO GOOD FOR GIVING A
PROSTATE EXAM TO THE HUMAN
TORCH.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ).
>> CHRIS: WELL PLAYED.
EXCELLENT.
AND, OF COURSE, WHO CAN DEAL
WITH PESKY, UNNECESSARY
SEATBELTS.
I PRESENT THE TIDDY BEAR.
>> WHEN YOU TRAVEL, IS YOUR
SHOULDER STRAP TOO TIGHT AND
ANNOYING?
INTRODUCING THE TIDDY BEAR.
THAT'S T-I-D-D-Y BEAR.
THE CUTE GUY THAT ELIMINATES
THOSE IRRITATING SHOULDER
STRAPS.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: FROM THE MAKER OF THE
PUSSY OTTER FOR LAP BELTS.
KURT?
>> WARNING-- BEAR LOVES TO MOTOR
BOAT AND WILL ( BLEEP ) ON YOUR
CHEST.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MARY LYNN.
>> TITS ARE WEIRD, RIGHT, CHRIS.
OH, TITTIES.
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE -- HERE'S A
NEEDLESSLY PORTABLE CHAIR.
>> NO MORE SITTING ON THE
GROUND.
NO MORE STANDING AROUND, AND NO
MORE FOLDING CHAIR FRUSTRATION.
NOW THAT'S AN AMAZING CHAIR.
>> THIS POCKET CHAIR IS A
LIFESAVER.
>> CHRIS: EVEN THIS CHILD LOOKS
UNCOMFORTABLE.
( LAUGHTER )
MARY LYNN?
>> FROM THE MAKERS OF TABLE HAT
AND COFFEE MAKER EARRINGS.
( LAUGHTER )
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
I WANT A TABLE HAT.
>> PUT IT ON YOUR HEAD.
IT'S REAL EASY TO GET AROUND
WITH.
SOLID OAK.
>> CHRIS: LAST UP, A TALKIE
PARROT MADE OF PLASTIC.
>> CHATTY PATTY.
SHE'S THE PARROT THAT TALKS
BACK.
GIVE HER A COMPLIMENT AND SHE'LL
GIVE IT BACK.
>> YOU'RE PRETTY.
>> YOU'RE SO NICE.
>> WELL, THANK YOU.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: THAT POOR, LONELY
WOMAN.
THOMAS.
>> CHATTY PATTY WILL ALSO TEACH
YOU HOW TO TIE A NOOSE.
>> CHRIS: ( BLEEP ).
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: KURT.
>> COMES PREPROGRAMMED WITH
PHRASES YOU NEVER HEAR LIKE, "I
LOVE YOU," AND "YOU'RE
IMPORTANT."
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MARY LYNN.
>> THIS PARROT WON'T LEAVE YOU
LIKE HE DID.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> I'M FINE.